so we talked about ghosts but you also
have a new movie coming out soon right
is it a rap musical yes okay I want to
see it I yeah it's uh coming on Disney
plus thanks to everyone at Disney for
helping us make a Disney movie it's like
a dream come true of mine it's called
world's best and I wrote it with my
friend Jamie King and I wrote the music
with my friend Charlie Bethel and Tommy
kale who directed Hamilton is producing
it with me wow it's about a young boy
named praying Patel he's a math whiz
which doesn't go over very well at his
school and he finds out that his dad was
a world famous rapper and his dad has
passed away because I wanted to play a
ghost for once in my freaking life and I
start to visit this kid and teach him
how to become the world's best MC and
through our relationship and through his
relationship he kind of it's a
coming-of-age story and it's fun and
sweet and full of music and I grew up
without having anyone who looked like me
on screen and my heroes were from all
different areas of the world but I never
saw South Asia kid in a lead role and so
for me it was really important to live
out that childhood dream through this
kid Manny Magnus who he found who's just
exceptional
um and plus I'm too old to play a 12
year old
um
I'm sorry I'm 39 I'm Dad I'm dad now I'm
I'm ghost dad now
um but we were just so excited and I
can't wait for you guys to hear the
music and and see the movie yeah
[Music]
[Applause]